[Music]
oh you're getting aggressive now yeah
[Music]
[Music]
this journey this road that i travel on
it all seems crazy over the years i
picked up thousands of tiger lungs
inspired by my story from a juvenile
where my clothes had holes in them and
my afro was picky
to the night east moschino and versace
no laces in her cheese new millennium
assalamu alaikum brothers and sisters
and dear friends i'm gonna show you guys
a clip
it was the first week that was back at
speaker's corner and yes because kind of
gets a bit wild
it gets a bit intense it can get a
little bit aggressive as well
and i've been going there for about five
six years now the reason i'm doing this
video is not to justify anything at all
it's just to talk to you guys about
history and what exactly
has been going in the park the park has
been there for about 150
maybe more than that it's a historical
place where people come and have
discussions and debates
now when i went to the park for about
one hour
full a group of christian crusaders like
this
missionary activity at the park would
you say it's conducive to
dialogue
this method of discussion is not it's
not conducive it's not it's not
it's not practical
[Music]
this is what i think about atheism no
you're wrong or you're wrong shut up
shut your mouth shut up no no no what
about what about the quran what about
this
it's not a way to discuss respect it's
not going to charity
and um that's what i'm going to call
them you know they're actually malicious
one of them is admitting this in a
clip he claims he said he's got a
t-shirt on that supposed christian
militia
imagine if i had a a t-shirt that
supported isis or something like that
what would have happened but he can
openly come and say i'm a christian uh
militia
you know uh saying this to the person
that he's speaking to another muslim and
this muslim just
you know is very pacifist about it
what's happening
how are you good i was just asking him
you know is it
you know but anyways the point is this
recently in the past decade or so
the christians have changed their way of
giving
their so-called their doubt their
apologetics yeah
it's totally changed before back in the
days
it was you know you can talk about the
trinity and the bible and jesus's love
and the holy spirit and love love love
and we love everybody and so but it's
starting to really change
now let's watch this clip this was the
first time after the lockdown that i've
come to the park
set up my stool as peaceful and for one
and
one hour non-stop uh heckling
it's the park it's normal it happens i
totally ignored it and also we had
another individual who's psychologically
disturbed
insulting swearing i just thought it
ignored it because you can't be crazy
with a crazy person
now watch the following clip in the
following clip i go to pray
on my way back my own property which
belongs to our organization salaam
somebody who's sitting on it this
individual which everybody knows
which her voice could actually kill
somebody and if she is married her
husband probably
would hang himself now what happened was
the following brother sisters
is that i came back after prayer and i
saw her sitting and she knows very well
and she out of
respect at least she has a bit of
respect she got up and i thought okay
it's my property
i came and got it now let's watch this
carefully i'm going to come back
did you know
no one wants to talk to you jesus
[Music]
uh
this is what you know
there you go
what happened
did you
now yeah
[Music]
don't be a hero
now what did you guys see there brother
sisters yeah
i got my property she comes violently
takes it back to sit on it
and i move it before she sits on it and
she bounces on the floor
because of gravity you know you know the
gravity the law of gravity
couldn't help but you know she fell down
like a basketball and bounced
and i had no sympathy for her at all and
i have no regrets and i would have done
the same thing
again and again and again now what
happened is a group of christian
crusaders
including bob and another guy um you
know he's
i don't know who he was here this is a
militia christian militia coming to the
rescue you know
this uh attitude so the question needs
to be asked is why
are christians in the last decade have
changed their whole way of giving
their dawah their apologetics they do
not talk about the trinity anymore
they do not mention the bible at all
some of them actually reject them i
wouldn't accept that it's been corrupted
they do not talk about jesus
they do not talk about the holy spirit
they do not talk about the father they
do not talk about paul mark matthew luke
or john none of that
and all of them do one thing very and
all of this
and all of them do something very
strange which is what
they have now started to talk about
islam nothing
but islam now one begs the question why
let's go in history in the year 850.
there was about 48 of between 47 to 47
to 50
christian missionaries they were called
the martyrs of cordoba
in spain under the rule of the islamic
empire
and what were these christians doing
with these missionaries they realized
that a lot of christians were leaving
christianity and embracing islam and
that really got to them
and intellectually they knew they had no
ground
it was baseless and that's exactly
what's happening again today and what
did they go down the route of
marta now this lady should try to be
martyred by falling on the floor
but no one really bought it but they
were actually blaspheming insulting the
prophet
in public knowing the execution was
going to be the capital punishment
that didn't stop them why because they
wanted their fellow christians to
sympathize
and not become muslims brothers and
sisters the same thing is being
done here these people have
adopted hate so much it has gone in
within them so much
that forget talking about their own
faith that
totally abundant and what why do they do
that because shahada does happen
over and over and over again in the park
and guess what
after that incident we had a beautiful
yeah well i'm gonna call him a young man
he's in his i would say 34 is came
michael who accepted islam in salaam
corner
and that made perfect sense because i
have never in my life come across anyone
in speaker's corner that's accepted
christianity
now i'm not here to say one is better
this doesn't
someone accepting islam that makes it
true what i'm saying is that brothers
and sisters
if this is happening and these people
are resorting to this and slowly you can
see that they are
raging enraging in there because we're
just we're just totally ignoring them
this shows you brothers and sisters how
powerful islam is and when i see this
visually with my own self
and see the insults that the prophet
saws gets and we get and we get attacked
while it reminds us of what what the
ambiya went through
and it also reminds us how strong islam
is that these people cannot
attack it theologically academically
intellectually
but all they have to do is heckling
abuse and
martyring themselves on the floor like a
basketball
brothers and sisters be aware and make
sure
that you do not buy this ignore it smile
at their faces
and carry on being an ambassador of
islam like our brother is merchant who
is a brilliant example with his akhlaq
and his adap
and we are going to carry that inshallah
this was a little reminder and here's a
little full clip
of her falling again isn't it
interesting till next time
assalamu alaykum in this beautiful day
to the beautiful souls watching there
inshallah and if you want to accept
islam please come visit our speaker's
corner and we can have some discussions
oh